okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the basics of waves so we can look
at the key features of a wave I'm going
to look at the difference between
transverse waves and longitudinal waves
so to begin with the very fundamental
fact of a wave is it transfers energy
from one place to another without
transferring every every any matter so
it's just about transferring energy from
one place to another
so I'm just gonna draw a wave for us now
and we're gonna label it so one two okay
so what we have right here is a wave
this actually is a transverse wave
so these top bits here it's called the
crest of the wave you might have heard
of this in surfing and here this bottom
part is called a trough this middle kind
of section here is the rest position so
notice how the wave goes above and below
the rest position so like I said
previously a wave is how we transfer
energy in this case and as you've been
transferred from here to here so some
other key features now this here is
called the amplitude so the amplitude is
the displacement from the rest position
to the crest a really key one that we
need to know is the wavelength so the
wavelength is the distance either from
one crest to another crest or from one
trough to another trough both of these
show the wavelength just nicely but it's
the length of the wave so it's measured
in meters because length is measured in
meters now what we also need to know is
something called frequency so the
frequency is basically how many waves
pass a point in one second so if one
wave passes a point in one second as a
frequency of one Hertz let's say if
twenty waves pass a point in one second
it would have a frequency of 20 Hertz
now let's say this particular wave we're
looking at let's say this is how many
waves passed in one second we could say
there's one two waves we'd say this wave
had a frequency of two Hertz so that's
what frequency means now the final thing
we need to know about wave basics is
this term period so the period is
basically the number of seconds it takes
to complete one wave cycle so in order
to find that you do 1 divided by the
office or whoops 1 divided by the
frequency so in this particular case it
would be 1 divided by 2 which equals 0.5
seconds because it would take half a
second for one wave to complete so that
is what period means the number of
number of seconds it can takes to
complete one full cycle to find it 1
over frequency so what we're going to do
now is we're going to look at the
difference between transverse waves and
longitudinal waves so we've already had
a look at a transverse wave so we're not
going to real able this one and so the
key things to remember about transverse
waves is the vibrations for the
transverse waves are at 90 degrees to
the wave direction so this is the big
distinction one big distinction between
these two it's the vibration for this
wave is going up and down but the wave
direction is traveling that way the
energy is being transferred into that
direction there so in a transverse wave
the vibe the vibrations are at 90
degrees the wave direction I remember
transverse waves because they're the
ones that look like they go from
side-to-side transverse and side-to-side
so the examples we need to know a few
examples of transverse waves as well so
basically any single part every single
part of the electromagnetic spectrum
so radio waves microwaves infrared
visible light ultraviolet x-rays gamma
rays all of those are all transverse
waves also S waves now these are a type
of seismic waves given off by
earthquakes remember again trans
verse s waves that's a nice way of
remembering it as well and the final one
we need to really example we really need
to know at this level is ripples and
waves in water but also examples of
these type of transverse waves so now we
need to learn about longitudinal waves
so longitudinal waves are really really
quite different from transverse waves in
longitudinal waves what we have is we
have a series of these things called
compressions and then these things could
rarefactions
which kind of show what's happening
which well let me explain so when we
have loads and loads of these waves all
kind of compressed together squashed up
this is called a compression when we
have this section here where there is
this kind of gap between the waves this
here is called a rarefaction now again
we do have a wavelength within these
waves as well because the wavelength is
the distance between two compressions so
just as before the wavelength is
measured in meters because it's
essentially the length between waves but
it's slightly different than in
transverse waves now another big
difference is in longitudinal waves the
direction of the vibrations are in the
same direction in the same direction to
wave travel or the wave direction so the
vibrations in a longitudinal wave goes
forwards and backwards like this and the
wave kind of travels that way as well so
that energy is transferred that way so
can we see it's completely different
from transverse waves where the
vibrations are at 90 degrees so just to
finish up the two main examples we need
to know for longer to dinner waves are
sound waves and the final one P waves
again P waves are another tie
seismic wave so that's everything we
need to know about wave basics and the
difference between transverse waves and
longitudinal waves thank you